- Good afternoon, everybody.
Welcome.
This is my first silent session,
so if my voice modulation is slightly off,
please bear with me.
The talk is gonna be strongly consistent,
and I'm hoping you guys
will eventually hear it.
So that's good.
So my name is Somu Perianayagam.
I'm an engineer at AWS.
I have Amrith Kumar with me
who is a senior principal
in Amazon by DynamoDB.
We both are here to talk to you guys
about the two replication modes
of DynamoDB Global Tables,
the guarantees they offer,
and what to choose for
what kind of workload.
Customers today are building
systems that need the data
close to their end users,
and their end users
are all over the globe,
are multi-regions, and this
can be for variety of reasons.
This can be for reasons for low latency
or compliance reasons,
geo compliance reasons.
But a lot of customers
are building applications
and systems where data has to
be close to their end users.
They also want these data
to be highly available.
What do I mean by that?
They want the writes
which happen in any region
to be available in other regions as well,
simultaneously, right?
And they need high business continuity
in case of regional service disruptions.
If one region goes down,
they may want to kind of have
high business continuity
for their applications.
These requirements are making customers
and a lot of applications
multi-region by default.
And this means the database
also needs to now start
growing to be multi-region by default.
DynamoDB global tables was created exactly
to kind of support this kind
of multi-region architectures.
But multi-region, unlike
single region is hard.
just because regions are very far apart,
they're across oceans, the
latencies are very variable.
That means when you write
a data in another region,
it's gonna take some time to
propagate to a region far away.
For example, a ride from Virginia to Tokyo
may take a couple of hundred milliseconds,
while a ride from Virginia to
Ohio may take 20 milliseconds.
And this is a very different
latency profile than a write
which is replicated within a region.
And if your architecture
now allows multiple writes
across multiple different
copies of this data,
then you have to reason about
how are these writes ordered,
how are these writes propagated?
What is the order in which the writes
will be visible to end customers?
These fundamental realities mean
that there's no one
single replication model
that would fit every workload.
Hence, DynamoDB Global tables offers
two different kind of replication models
for different workloads.
As you build these
multi-region architectures,
you have to kind of have some trade offs,
and of the biggest trade offs
is do you want your application to be fast
and have predictable performance
as it would when it
writes to a single region?
Or do you want writes to be
visible across multiple regions?
If a write is done in one region,
do you want it to be
visible in other regions?
Because this communication of
writes going across regions
is gonna have a latency penalty,
which means that you'll have
to lose sacrifice of latency
or you have to sacrifice consistency.
And DynamoDB global tables has two modes.
One is the asynchronous replication mode,
which helps you have high
performance, low latency,
predictable performance,
sort of predict perform workload,
while multi-region strong
consistency global tables,
which is a whole mouthful to say,
so we're gonna call it MRSC Global Tables,
which is suited for
workloads which requires
strong consistency where
write in any region
needs to be visible in other regions,
where it's strong if it's read.
The other big trade offs around
what is the recovery point objective
and what is the recovery time objective.
The recovery time objective
is objective where
how seamlessly can your
application failover
from one region to another region,
or how quickly can your
application recover from a failure?
DynamoDB global tables,
from the ground or from first principles,
was designed as the
active-active architecture
so that you don't have to worry about this
and you can have an
application architecture
which has a recovery
time objective of zero.
The recovery point objective
is an interesting one.
It's the objective that says,
how much data can I
recreate or offer to lose
if I have a service disruption
or if my service fails in a single region?
And this is going to drive how fast
you want to replicate writes
or how strongly consider your
writes have to be replicated
if you want a low RPO.
DynamoDB Global Tables' asynchronous
and MRSC Global Tables have
different RPO characteristics,
and your workload's now
gonna pick and choose
which trade-off they want to make.
With this, I'm gonna
hand it over to Amrith
to dive deep into the consistency models
and asynchronous global table replication.
Thanks, Amrith.
- Thank you, Somu.
So I need a quick show of hands from you
if you're able to hear me or not.
Okay, thank you.
My name is Amrith.
I, as Somu said, I work
on the DynamoDB team.
I'm a senior principal engineer.
I spend much of my time
working with customers.
And the thing I like the most
about that part of my job
is I get to see what it is
you're building with DynamoDB.
So I wanna talk to you a little bit about
eventually consistent global tables,
and I'll hand it back to
Somu who's gonna talk to you
about the strongly
consistent global tables.
What we're gonna cover,
consistency models,
use cases for multi-region global tables,
and Somu actually, I think,
is the brave one here.
He's gonna show you a live
demo, so that's gonna be fun.
Alright, so let's talk about consistency.
See, when you're building
applications in a database,
consistency is about whether your data
read in multiple places
is the same or different.
In a single instance database,
consistency is relatively easy.
You write your data,
you can read your data,
things are good.
DynamoDB, on the other hand,
is a distributed database,
and your data is stored
durably on multiple copies.
We'll talk about how many copies
and how we do it and so on.
In order for us to scale,
it is not possible for us
to always give you strong consistency.
Applications sometimes
need strong consistency.
What is strong consistency?
You write the data, everybody
should be able to see
the same data instantly.
Eventual consistency
is you write the data,
everybody will get to
see that data eventually.
In other words, if you do a
bunch of writes and then stop,
all copies of the data
will converge to one place.
That's eventual consistency.
If you're not able to
guarantee strong consistency
for everybody, it makes it
easier to build applications
if you're at least able to say,
"When I write some data,
I can read it back."
That's read-your-write consistency.
And the last one which I wanna point out
is something called monotonic reads.
With eventual consistency,
I said data converges to one place.
But suppose you were to do
multiple writes at T1, 2, 3, 4,
monotonic reads basically say
time will always move forward.
There are database architectures
where you can read one, three, two, four.
We do not give you that.
We always give you monotonic reads.
Okay.
To understand global tables,
you need to understand first
something about DynamoDB.
So this is a quick overview of DynamoDB.
You the customer over here,
this is your application.
You connect to DynamoDB over a network.
Your request goes through a
whole networking infrastructure,
load balancers, and all of that stuff,
but eventually makes its
way to a request router.
Your data is stored
over here on the right,
and this is shared infrastructure
used by all of our customers.
So we have millions of customers,
and they all share the
same infrastructure.
When your request makes its
way to a request router,
its job is to figure
out where your data is.
I want to read an item,
on which storage node is
your data actually stored?
That's its job.
In order to do that, it uses metadata.
Now, the most important
thing for us is to make sure
that we only show you the data
which you are allowed to see.
So we have to verify who you are,
authenticate you, authorize you.
Then we have rate-limiting to make sure
that you don't overdrive your database,
and then we send it
over to a storage node.
Now, for availability and durability,
we store three copies of your data
on three storage nodes,
in three different availability zones.
When you want to do a write,
your write always goes
to a storage node leader.
I just depicted leader
here with the crown.
So with that in mind, let's talk about
how an eventually consistent read works.
You send down a request, it
comes to a request router.
Since it's an eventually consistent read,
I can read any copy.
That's one of the reasons
why you have to understand
eventual consistency in your application,
because when you make a GetItem
call, you have to realize
that you may not be getting the
most recent version of data.
Your application has to understand that.
However, if you do want the
most recent version of the data,
you will do a strongly consistent read,
which is also something which we support.
Then we will send your
request to the leader.
The leader is always part of a write.
Therefore, it always has
your most recent data.
Everybody okay with this concept so far?
Yes, okay.
So when you want to go
from a single region setup,
now this was already
three availability zones,
but if you go from
three availability zones
in one region to multi-region,
you have to think about
a couple more things.
First, there's propagation
delay between regions.
Propagation delay between
AZs is always much shorter
than the propagation
delay between regions.
So this is something which
you have to consider.
When you write data to a table,
if it's a global table,
it's our responsibility
to get it over to the other region.
But in what order are
your writes sent across?
The guarantee we provide is
that on a per item basis,
data will be transferred
in the write order.
In other words, it is monotonic on it's,
you're never going to go back in time.
It's monotonic on the other direction,
on the other region as well.
Global tables are also active-active.
So your application could
legitimately be running
in multiple regions.
We have global tables
which are in 30 regions.
We're responsible for the replication.
Your application can be writing anywhere,
but if multiple parts, multiple locations
were to modify the same item,
what is the item finally
gonna converge to?
We use timestamps for conflict resolution,
so we'll talk about that as well.
And finally, we're gonna
talk about failure scenarios,
various different failure scenarios
and how we deal with them.
So let's talk about actually the way
in which replication works.
I have here a picture of a global table.
I'm showing two copies.
We'll get to multiple copies as well.
So in us-east-1, I have a table copy,
and in another region,
whichever region it is, I have a replica.
Whenever you make a change to a table,
DynamoDB will first
perform the write locally.
And to perform a write locally,
it means it has to be written
in two availability zones.
Once the write is written
durably in this region,
it goes to a replicator,
and the replicator job is,
replicator is going to read from streams.
This is normally the symbol for streams.
The replicator job is to read from streams
and propagate to the other region, okay?
So the sequence is you
perform a write in region one.
Once the write is durably
written, it goes to streams,
the replicator pulls the stream
and writes it to the other region.
Fairly straightforward, correct?
This is two regions.
What do you do if you
have multiple regions?
One possible architecture
is to have one replicator
for multiple regions.
We don't.
We have one replicator per region.
And the reason we do that
is because we want each path
to be its own individual failure domain.
Let's assume that us-east-1 has a problem
writing to this region, whatever it is,
that should not have
any impact on this path.
Therefore, your write
comes in to us-east-1.
where you perform the write,
it goes through streams.
Now you have multiple
replicators, one per target region
performing the replication into the other.
The exact same scenario can be played
in the opposite direction as well.
Us-east-1 becomes whatever
the remote region is,
and it has a replicator in that direction.
Replicators are unidirectional.
So from us-east-1 to
destination region replicator,
in the opposite direction,
another replicator.
And this is the reason why
these are eventually consistent.
You perform the write here.
The write is durably recorded.
If you do a strongly
consistent read in this region,
you're gonna see that data.
There is a propagation delay
before it makes its way over there,
but it will eventually get there.
That's the eventually consistent
part of global tables.
So let's assume you have a
table, it has end regions.
Like I said, each region to another region
is a pairwise replication mechanism.
This arrow just shows
that there's a replicator
in one direction or replicator
in the other direction.
So what happens if you
have various failure?
Oh, let's first talk about
timing diagrams, okay.
Time progresses forward.
We have four regions here in this picture.
I perform a write in region one.
That write is durably
recorded in region one,
and it's then replicated to region two.
Everybody good with this
representation so far?
Yes, okay.
That replication makes its
way over to region three.
That replication makes
its way over to region two
but at different time.
Each of these is an
independent replication stream.
Of course there's one more here.
The important thing to realize
is all these replications
happen at different times.
Okay, they're all independent.
Now, let's assume that I do a write.
The write is successful.
I got a 200 on the write,
I perform a consistent read.
Whatever I wrote will be
visible in that consistent read.
Okay, what happens here?
I did the write, the
replicator has got the data.
The write only happens here.
A consistent read here
will not show you the data.
Remember that strongly consistent reads
in eventually consistent global tables,
strongly consistent reads
in eventually consistent
global tables only reflect
those writes which are in that region.
A strongly consistent read
in this region will reflect this write.
A strongly consistent read here
may not reflect that write.
Again, the write was replicated.
It will see it.
When you're building your application,
realize that just because you
do a strongly consistent read
on an eventually consistent global table,
it does not guarantee that
you've got the latest data.
Okay?
What happens about ordering?
I told you that ordering
is on a per key basis.
Let's assume that these
are two different items.
On the first item, the
initial state is 10,
on another item, the initial state is 200.
I perform a write, "A equals 11."
This item has been modified.
At a later time, I write, "B equals 201."
So these are two writes
which occur in this order.
This replication comes over here.
This replication happens
at a completely different time there.
On a per item basis, A,
or another item basis, B,
we will guarantee that the replications
are going to be in order.
But across items, we cannot
guarantee the same thing.
The replication streams are independent.
Therefore, this replication happens here,
the other replication happens here.
Notice, this write
happens after this write.
On a per item basis, we can
guarantee monotonic reads
across items we cannot,
across keys we cannot.
Okay?
And the last thing we'll talk
about is conflict resolution.
If you have an active-active system
and in multiple regions
you modify the same item,
which one are we going to survive?
It's the last write.
So all of our regions share atomic locks.
We know exactly what time
you're performing the write.
You do it write in two regions.
No matter how close you think they are,
one is gonna be before the other.
The one which is later will always win.
So how do we go about doing that?
Let's assume that this is an item
which we're accepting a write for.
I'm going to record, as part of the write,
that it came in the IAD
region at a timestamp of 10.
I'm gonna propagate it over,
along with the timestamp.
If there is a write in the
other region at timestamp 11,
this write is gonna be ignored,
because this is at an earlier timestamp.
Last writer wins.
And of course, if there's
a write at timestamp 11,
it'll propagate in the opposite direction.
Therefore, both regions will
converge to timestamp 11, okay?
So conflict resolution
using a timing diagram,
at approximately the same time,
the write is done in two regions.
Both of them are gonna replicate forward.
This time here, 20 and 30,
indicates the time at
which the write happened.
Since this write says 20,
a subsequent write which says
timestamp 30 will overwrite.
Therefore, in region one,
you do the write at time 20.
A subsequent replication
of the write at 30
is going to override it.
Similarly, replication into this region
where there were no
writes, R1 happens first,
this write comes in first,
this one comes in second.
It is going to converge here.
Take a look at what happens here.
You performed a write at time 30.
The replicator sent down
something at time 20.
We dropped it.
Same thing here.
The replicator came down
here with 20, it dropped it.
Important consequence of
this is that in region one,
you will see a streams
notification for this
and a streams notification for this,
if you're building an application
using DynamoDB streams.
In this region, you will
see a notification for 20
and then a notification for 30.
In this region, you will only
see a notification for 30.
In this region, you will see
only a notification for 30.
You will never see this notification.
So if you're building
a streams application,
realize the consequence
of having eventual consistency
in your global table, okay?
And the last thing we'll
talk about is failure modes.
A three region global table, us-east-1,
us-east-2, and us-west-2.
For whatever reason, us-east-2 is offline.
Nothing happens to the lubrication
between us-east-1 and us-west-2.
That continues just fine.
You can write data here,
it just doesn't get propagated over there.
You can write data here.
It gets over to us-east-1.
It doesn't go over to
us-east-2, that's all.
At some point, when
us-east-2 comes back online,
we do the catch up, and the data
in all three regions will again converge.
Last writer wins.
Okay, slightly different scenario.
Us-east-2 is perfectly running here.
There's a network partition.
Any write in us-east-1 will
make its way over to us-west-2.
Any write in us-east-2 can't make it over.
So in this condition, all
three tables are active.
This table can serve reads and writes.
It is just gonna be serving
data which is local.
When the network links are reestablished,
data will come over.
Again, we will converge event
to the last writer wins.
And the last one I'll talk about
is this particular failure
mode where one network breaks.
I want you to listen
to this one carefully,
because this is something
where eventually consistent
global tables differ
from strongly consistent
global tables when someone gets to it.
Any write in us-east-1 will be
propagated over to us-west-2.
Any write in us-east-2 will
be propagated to us-west-2.
Any write in us-west-2
will be propagated to both.
A write in us-east-1
will not go to us-east-2.
We do not relay.
A write to east-2 will
not go to us-east-1.
We don't relay the write.
Therefore, a write here goes to both.
A write here does not
make its way over there.
When the network link is reestablished,
that would be reestablished, okay?
Keep that in mind because it's different
in strongly consistent global tables.
So I mentioned streams
earlier on the timing diagram.
Remember that your
stream will only reflect
those writes which actually happen.
If you get a replicated
write which is stale,
you will not get a streams notification.
You will only get all writes
which are actually written.
So you will get any
write in the local region
and replicated writes
may not happen, okay.
If you were to perform a
transaction in a region,
we guarantee asset
transactions in the region.
Remember that replication
is on a per item basis.
Therefore, it's possible for you
to see a torn transaction
in the remote region.
If you're building an applications
which needs transactions,
remember that eventually
consistent global tables
may show you a torn transaction
in a remote region, okay?
With that, I'm gonna hand it back to Somu,
and he'll talk to you about
strongly consistent global tables.
- Thanks, Amrith.
Thanks for the deep dive into
asynchronous global tables
and how the application works.
Some of the slides were
eventually consistent,
but that's okay.
So we build asynchronous global tables,
a lot of customers loved
it for their workload
and gained a lot of adoption.
But customers still wanted
to read their writes from any region.
Some applications got
really smart about this.
They said, "Let's take
asynchronous global tables,
let's assign a single region
as a designated leader
and writer and we're gonna read
and write from that region."
This is like pretty
much like my household.
We have my wife as a designated leader.
Everything goes through my
wife in the house, right?
It works fine.
The latency profile of
the reads and writes
depend on how far the regions are, right?
And it's very different from every region.
So strongly consistent
reads will have to go back
to the designated region
and it's (indistinct).
But if a wife is not at home,
now my kids and I have to
kind of reconcile the stuff
and see who's right.
And that becomes a problem,
because once a designated
leader region is not available
because of a network
partition or something else,
then we have to figure out
whether the latest write
in that region is available
to the other regions or not.
Other regions have to
reconcile this stuff,
and you'll have to have
a failover protocol
in the application to
take care of this new,
getting a new designated region,
which will be the leader,
writer and reader for all
the writes, reads and writes.
Similarly, some other
applications said, "You know what?
We're gonna get around
this whole write problem
and having higher latencies,
we're gonna write locally,
and then we have to do
strongly consistent reads
because it's a small
part of our application,
we are gonna do a read
from all the regions
and see which region
has the latest write."
This works fine, but again,
the strongly consistent
reads is gonna be very slow,
as low as the region which
is farthest away from you,
because you had to read all
the writes from that region.
And if that region is not available,
you don't know how to reconcile
all the reads you have.
So this becomes problematic.
To take away the differentiated
heavyweight lifting
from customers, we built this feature
into DynamoDB global tables.
We build multi-region strong consistency
DynamoDB global tables, which
solves region writes problem,
makes writes highly available,
even in case of region failures,
and make strongly consistent
reads serializable
at an item level with all the writes
that have happened to the item.
So how do my wife and
I solve this problem?
We have a joint calendar, we
can share that and take notes
and we build a basic primitive block
journal which spans multiple regions
as the replicas of the global table.
This journal is append-only log,
and the journal would
successfully append the log
It's able to kind of durably
commit and store the log
in two of the three regions.
And on top of that, all
the logs from the journal
are delivered to the clients
in the order the journal appends them.
Since the journal can
have multiple clients,
you have three different
regions writing to the journal.
Then you want the clients
listening to the journal
to receive the logs in the
order the journal sees it,
not in the order the
clients are appending it.
So the journal actually
provides an interface
where all the clients are
getting logs delivered
in the order the journal
has appended the logs.
Now, how does the write
work in case of multi-region
strongly consistent global
table write request?
As soon as the write request comes,
it is forwarded to a
GT replication engine.
But this replication engine is different
from the asynchronous global tables.
This one is inside than DynamoDB
as opposed to the other one
which was waiting for the streams
and asynchronous replicating it.
This replication engine has
two key functionalities.
One is generating the
replication log entries for,
generating replication log entries
and opening it to multi-region journal.
And second is to listen to
the multi-region journal
and applying all the
log entries in the order
it's appended on the journal.
So the replicated usually reads
from the local DynamoDB table, says,
"Hey, what is the state of the item
you're writing to this item?"
Generates a log entry and appends it
to the multi-region journal.
Once it's successfully
appended the journal,
you get a call back
from the journal saying,
"Hey, I have a new log
entry for you guys,"
and it sends it to all
the replication engines
in all the three regions.
And then all the three
regions apply the log entry,
they can apply it anytime
they want to apply,
but the region in which the write happens,
the application's done immediately
and a success or failure is
written back to the customer.
Now, this is the same request flow diagram
but just in a timeline
to just kind of set pace
along with the slides.
The write happens, the
log entries appended,
and then you get a call
back in each of the regions
and you can see the
application of the log entry
can happen at various points,
various timelines in different regions.
But the region in which
the write originates
returns the 200 once it
applies that log entry.
Now, what happens if there
are concurrent writes
to different items from different regions?
In this example, we have two regions
having two writes to two different items.
It might seem that the write A
arrives at R1 before write B,
but since write B is appended
in the journal before write A,
write B is applied by all the regions
before write A is applied.
So journal allows you to kind
of serialize these two writes.
Journal serializes the writes for you
in the order in which
it appends log entries.
Now, how do strongly consistent reads work
in case of multi-region strongly
consistent global tables?
The key thing here is to know
that when a strongly consistent read
arrives in a particular region,
that that particular
region has all the writes.
It's not gonna miss any writes
from any of the regions.
And the only way for that read to know
that there are no writes
that's not applied
is by ensuring that it has applied
everything from the journal.
How do we kind of ensure that
everything from the journal
is applied before the read is served?
We use a read fence, or
tracer bullet, or heartbeat,
whatever you call, it's another log entry.
This log entry is appended
to the multi-region journal.
And then we listen to all the log entries.
We try to listen to the heartbeat.
But as a part of listening
to the heartbeat,
we'll also listen to all
the other log entries
which we have not applied so far.
So we will start applying
all those log entries
which we've not applied so far
until we reach the heartbeat.
And once the heartbeat arrives,
we can be sure that, one,
we've seen all the
writes in all the regions
because the heartbeat is serialized,
along with the other writes
in the journal, right?
And you've seen all the
writes before the heartbeat.
So this acts as a read fence,
and now we can successfully,
you can correctly say that, yes,
this strongly consistent
read is gonna return
the latest version of the item,
no matter which region
the item is returned to.
Now, the protocol is the same,
even if you have a single-region write
and you're reading
strongly from that region,
because it ensures correctness
and there's no bad behavior.
But the thing to keep in mind and remember
is that since the heartbeat
also goes through the journal
and appends the journal, you
pay the penalty of the write.
The latency of the
strongly consistent reads
is almost equal to the latency of writes.
Now, last year we did,
we actually had multi-region
strongly consistent tables
in preview, and at that point in time,
it was launched as a three-region replica,
global table replica.
We got some amazing feedback
from you guys saying that,
"Hey, two regions is more
than sufficient for us.
A third region is not necessary
because it will incur operational cost
and the cost of having a DynamoDB
table in a third region."
So before we went GA, we
launched a witness region,
and what a witness region allows you,
what a witness region allows us to do
is that for multi-region journal,
we need at least three regions,
because the journal has
to append two regions
to successfully kind of say,
yes, the log is durably committed.
But if there's a region disruption,
then you don't have two regions.
So we need three regions, at
least for multi-region journal.
So the witness region is just saying that,
hey, your multi-region
journal spans three regions,
but you don't have to have
a DynamoDB table in the witness region.
So you have no resource, no
cost, no operational cost
to kind of maintaining a witness region.
So MRSC global tables
supports two full replicas
and a witness region.
We did talk about
asynchronous global tables
and how it resolves concurrent writes.
And for MRSC global tables,
it's very easy on how to
resolve concurrent writes,
because you're writing to the
multi-region journal, right?
So if there are two writes,
it's gonna write to the same journal,
they're gonna get serialized.
But the important point here is,
what is that we write to the journal?
What is that replication log
entry we write to the journal
and why do we do this?
So we write a very important
replication log into the journal.
The reason for this is that we want it
to be applied at most
once, no matter what,
because a GD replicator can
read the replication log
reapply and fail after
that or crash after that,
and then it might restart
from the previous checkpoint
from the journal to start listening
and try to reapply the logs.
So we make the log entries idempotent.
And how do we do that?
Like everything Dynamo, Dynamo supports
optimistic concurrency control.
So we just take any request that comes in,
read the current item, and convert it
to a conditional write,
conditional insert or conditional delete.
For example, here I'm
incrementing the counter
of the number of attendees
for re:Invent 2025, right?
When this request comes into a region,
it'll read the current state of the item
and generate an insert log entry.
And this insert log entry is conditioned
based on the timestamp which
we store a system metadata
for every global table
item we have, right?
And says, "Okay, fine, update the item
to the value seven from six,
if the timestamp matches
whatever the previous
timestamp on the item is."
And then we also increment the system
to show the new timestamp.
Now, let's see how this works.
Now I have two increment re:Invent calls
from two different regions.
Both of them are gonna generate
replication log entries
which look almost identical,
except that one of them
may have a different timestamp,
new timestamp on the item
versus other one, right?
Now, each of these regions
are gonna get a call back
for each log entries in the order.
So region R2's log entry
will be applied first,
and you'll get a success
back in region R2.
It's great.
What happens when both the regions
read the second log entry?
They will not be able to do this insert,
again, because this is a
put item with a condition,
and the condition doesn't match anymore.
So R2 is gonna say, "I can't apply it.
I'm just gonna skip this log entry."
R1 will write a failure to
the application, saying,
"Hey, there was a
replicated write conflict.
Please retry this write again."
Usually, the SDK is smart
enough to retry this
because it's a retriable exception.
So SDK would retry this
exception for most applications.
Multi-region strongly consistent,
MRSC global tables and
failures, like we said,
we went through strongly
consistent reads, how do they work.
We've talked about write
conflicts, how do we handle.
The other key thing is like understanding
the failure characteristics.
What happens in case of failures?
How do these tables behave?
Since the regional
latencies are different,
if a region is completely isolated,
that region is not gonna be
able to serve first any writes
or strongly consistent reads,
because it can't write
to the journal, right?
And it can't serve any writes.
But interestingly enough,
before the partition,
us-east-1 would've had a very good latency
in terms of writes and
strongly consistent reads,
because its closest
neighbors to us-east-2.
So it only needs us-east-2 to acknowledge,
us-east-2 itself to
acknowledge any write quickly.
But once us-east-2 is isolated,
it has to pair up at the us-west-2
for all the journal comments
and all the journal appends,
which means the latency of
the application would increase
if you have one region,
if you have your closest
region completely isolated.
Now, if there is a network partition
between us-east-1 and us-east-2,
this is the most interesting use case.
This is the most interesting
failure scenario.
In case of asynchronous global tables,
if there is a network partition
between us-east-1 and
us-east-2, the replication stops
because it's a point to point replication.
But in case of MRSC global tables,
it actually works because in steady state,
us-east-1 is replicating logs
to us-east-2 all the time
and us-west-2.
But if there is a network partition
between us-east-1 and us-east-2,
those replication logs
just take a longer route.
They just travel through
us-west-2 to us-east-2.
So any replication logs
even from us-east-2
to us-east-1 will travel via us-west-2.
So your application latencies will go up
because network partition
and the replication logs
will have to take a longer path.
But all regions will be available
for strongly consistent reads and writes.
This is a key difference between
asynchronous global tables
and MRSC global tables.
Now, Amrith was talking about
streams and transactions.
All writes to a key are visible
in the same order in all
regions for MRSC global tables.
For a given key visible in the same order,
that doesn't change with streams.
MRSC global tables don't
support transactions
and a time to expire still.
So these are two key
things to keep in mind
when you're kind of
using MRSC global tables
for any of your workload.
Now, this is just to recap,
what are the regional failures
and how do these two tables differ?
In case of regional failure,
again, asynchronous global tables remains,
both of them remain very highly available
in both of the regions, in
the remaining healthy regions.
In case of a network isolation,
again, they remain asynchronous.
Global tables is highly
available in all the regions.
Your reads are going to be very eventual,
will be stale, but writes
will be still available.
But in case of MRSC global
tables in the isolated region,
regions writes won't be available,
but the other regions
will be highly available.
Network partition, like I said,
they behave slightly different
across both these global tables.
Now one of the key things I get asked
everywhere I go is like,
"Hey, how do you guys gain
confidence in this protocol?"
This is complicated system.
All distributed systems are very hard.
And in Dynamo, one of the
things we kind of take
very seriously is distributed systems.
A human mind can't reason about it.
So we use a lot of tools
to help us kind of reason
and check our system in
variance all the time.
So for global tables, we use this new tool
called P-model checker, which
allows you to model the states
and transitions of an
item and the protocol
and validate it during runtime,
during application runtime.
Like as the global tables
protocol is running,
we can generate application logs
and validate that using P-observe.
And since P uses a language
which is very close to C-sharp,
it kind of easy to keep the
code and the model in sync.
So anytime you wanna change the code,
the practice is usually
to change the model first,
verify the protocol still works,
and then kind of modify the code.
A big part, like my
friends across the stage
were talking about was, how
do you build resiliency?
A big part of it is also
chaos and scale testing.
There's a lot of testing which goes
into all the failure modes
and how global tables
behave in failure mode.
So we do a lot of chaos
testing and scale testing
to ensure the protocols still work
and validate in variance of the system.
Last but not the least, anti-entropy.
For both all global table replicas,
we are performing anti-entropy always
to ensure there is no divergence
and writes usually converge
in case of asynchronous
global tables eventually,
and in case of MRSC global
tables, they are converged.
So we keep performing anti-entropy,
and this is a property we do
even for regional DynamoDB,
where we have three copies of the data
across different availability zones.
We have a system which
continuously performs anti-entropy
to verify the replicas have the same data.
We also have introduced an experiment
in AWS fault injection service,
which customers can use
to kind of test themselves
how their applications will behave
if there is a failure with global tables.
And I think this is very important
because we've tested a lot of the stuff,
and customers who need to
kind of test their failover,
how their application behaves
when there's a failure.
So we do support post-application
for DynamoDB global tables,
which would help you test
what happens if replication is paused
for asynchronous global tables.
- A couple of things
which Somu talked about,
first, we currently don't
support transactions
with strongly consistent global tables.
We are working on that.
If you use TTL, time to live,
it is supported with eventually
consistent global tables.
It will also be supported
with strongly consistent
global tables before long.
So keep those two things in mind.
When you're building your application,
one of the choices you're
gonna have to make is,
should you use eventually
consistent global tables
or strongly consistent global tables?
These are some of the things
you have to keep in mind.
With asynchronous global tables,
there is no write cost across regions.
Your writes are always
in the local region.
Your reads are always in
the local region as well.
With strongly consistent global tables,
even your strongly consistent reads
have to effectively go across regions.
That's the heartbeat which
someone was talking about.
So remember that a
strongly consistent read
has a latency of approximately
the same as write.
Availability, both of them are
going to be highly available,
but your data is instantly available
in the case of a strongly
consistent global table.
It's eventually consistent in the case
of a asynchronous global table.
Also, remember the network
isolation failure modes
are a little bit different.
This is the one which is most important
for your application to deal
with, and I strongly urge you,
when you are building an application
with either form of global tables,
to use the fault injection mechanism
and see how your application deals
with the failure of replication.
This is not something you should discover
in the middle of an event.
You should test this on a regular basis.
The other thing which you should do
if you are building an application
which is active-active,
it's really good that
you're driving traffic
to both the regions.
But if you are building an application
which is active at a standby region,
always please try to drive traffic
to the other region as well,
10%, 90% or do failovers
on a regular basis.
Do not make those things only
exercise during a failure.
Test continuously.
And again, the last one talks
about the kind of things
that you would expect to use
these different global tables for.
You wanna try again?
- Yeah, okay.
I think this is fine.
- All right.
- I'm sorry about that.
Sorry for the interruption.
Hope this time it works.
So I've reset the counters.
I'm choosing IAD as a region
where I'm gonna do the writes.
I'm gonna increment the counter
five times there in a loop.
While I'm incrementing the counter,
I'm gonna do strongly consistent reads
from the two other replicas I have,
which is one as in us-east-2
and one is a us-west-2,
and see what the experiment provides us.
So as you can see, in IAD,
the values went from 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
which is local writes, which is fine.
And in us-west-2, it's very interesting
that when it started reading
strongly consistent reads
for quite some time, we're
giving the same value
as eventually consistent reads.
And I ran 10 iterations
of it and it reads zero
and then skips directly to five.
It just sees five.
So you can see that it's an
asynchronous replication.
The eventual value kind of
comes over to us-west-2.
Likewise, since us-east-2 is nearby,
it does see zeros, threes,
threes, and this one.
But one of the key things to
notice here is the latency.
The latency down at the
strongly consistent read
and eventually consistent
reads is very low.
I mean, this is running on
my laptop but from Vegas.
So it's like about 80
milliseconds to all the regions.
But both reads are really, really fast
because they're talking
locally to the region
and they're not talking,
they're not using
strongly consistent reads
for MRSC global tables.
I'm gonna run the same experiment
with MRSC global tables
and let's see what we get.
So first, you can see that IAD writes
were almost the same time still.
Writing to one region is fine.
But you can see that
strongly consistent reads
and eventually consistent
reads now start seeing
the same values as they kind of
are incremented in IAD, for example.
And also, a key thing to notice
here is now your latencies
for the strongly consistent
reads have gone up
from 70 milliseconds to
about 200 milliseconds
because, like I said,
strongly consistent reads
for multi-region and
strongly consistent tables
do write to the journal,
so that latency does add up
when you're doing strongly
consistent reads, right?
Likewise, you can see
that they finally see,
they see most of the values throughout.
In some cases, you can
see for example here,
the strongly consistent read in us-west-2
does see the value of four,
but the eventually consistent
value here is three,
because it is reading a
local copy of the data
which may be stale, but
strongly considered read
is reading whatever is the
latest write, which has happened.
The second example I'm gonna show you
is a multi-writer example.
Here is where we are gonna
increment the counter
across all the regions
simultaneously, right?
I'm gonna have three different threads
incrementing the counter across
three different replicas.
So we'll see how this works
with asynchronous global tables first.
Run this experiment and you can see
that they all incremented
the counter five times,
but they just landed up with
the same value eventually
because they're not talking to each other,
the writes are not coordinated,
the writes are not
getting propagated before
the writes happen locally in the region.
So all three replicas land
up being the same value.
This works for applications
where you really don't need
the writes propagated across regions.
You can maintain separate
copies of the values.
So this is, well, and
you can see the latencies
are also very fast for the writes.
The latencies are almost as
good as how long it takes
from going from Vegas to
each of these regions.
We're gonna run the same experiment again
with MRSC tables and see what happens.
Since each of the region is incrementing
the counter five times,
you land up with the
final value of 14 and 15.
But you can see that
the values get increment
0, 1, 1, 2, 3, 4.
But there are some writes
where you can see the value.
The time taken is very high.
For example, in us-west-2,
the first write,
where its write is five and value is six,
you can see it's taken about
like half a second to write.
And if I were to go debug this stuff,
in all properties, this is because it got
a replicated write conflict the first time
it tried to increment the counter,
so it had to retry to
increment the counter again
in the region again.
So the retries do add up,
and you can kind of see
this latency kind of go up.
But you can see that all three regions
eventually convert to the same value of 15
after incrementing the value five times
in each of the regions.
So that was the part of the demo.
- Do you wanna hit that
switch for me again?
All right.
So we talked about how you make a choice
between using strongly
consistent global tables
and asynchronous global tables.
And let me just quickly recap
the things which we talked about.
Customers building applications
sometimes need the ability
to have data available
in multiple regions,
distributed applications
if you want to have
redundancy in the event that
there's a regional failure.
Some customers are able to
tolerate a non-zero value of RPO.
They are willing to
replay that data themself.
Others who are not will probably wanna use
strongly consistent global tables.
There are multiple trade offs
when you go from one region
to multiple regions,
and when you go from
multiple regions asynchronous
to multiple regions synchronous.
One of the things which we've realized
is that building applications which scale
is typically much easier
if you're able to embrace
eventual consistency.
If you require everything
to be done synchronously,
you are at the mercy of
having the long network lags.
If you're able to tolerate
eventual consistency,
you can do everything with the inter-AZ
or intra region costs.
How does dynamo DynamoDB behave
in single region versus multiple regions?
And the most important
thing is how to choose
the write model for your application.
But no matter which one you choose,
the one thing which I will
hope you take away is this.
Test your application in all
the possible failure states.
We do a lot of that.
We use P-model checkers.
For those of you who
are not familiar with P,
it's a much more recent version
of what you probably use,
which is TLA plus.
It is extremely useful
to verify your algorithms
are actually going to work
the way you expect them to
when there is a failure.
Thank you very much for your time.
We enjoy doing these presentations.
We'd love to get your feedback.
So please let us know what it
is you wanna hear next time
and we'll try and do that.
Please take the feedback
on your mobile app.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)